maxime de la viande des pommes de terre
et de l'avoine à rare qu'yves un ragoût
pour survivre ces hommes le prépare pour
les civils qui se cacha salvi de cas
dans un des quartiers les plus bombardés
il traverse ensuite la ville au péril de
leur vie depuis le début de la guerre il
y a deux mois rare qui vit au rythme des
bombardements russes constant et
indiscriminé nous sommes attaqués tous
les jours il n'y a pas une journée sans
attaque des taxes hausse 85 % des
habitants de cette ancienne cité dortoir
son parti ce chant
oseront-ils chauffage
nous n'avons rien ici nulle part où
cuisiner même pas de plaque électrique
quand le ravitaillement organisée par
les autorités locales peinent à arriver
jusqu'à eux ses habitants ne peuvent
compter que sur la solidarité pour
survivre
dieu mettre fin à cette guerre nous
allons tous devoir aller dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
nous allons tous des problèmes mentaux
maintenant
si rare qu'yves deuxième ville du pays
résistent depuis deux mois l'invasion
russe l'armée ukrainienne a reconnu ce
mercredi des avancées russe dans la
région